okay my name is Jim Levinson I'd like to
welcome everybody here we'll start on
time I guess general McChrystal's
reputation precedes him for those of you
who have had him in class you know that
you don't show up a minute late I think
it was during shopping period his first
year people came in its shopping period
it's like teaching school on a school
bus people are coming and going and I
neglected to tell general McChrystal
that people might be coming and going
someone walked in general McChrystal
looked at him and said son you're not
gonna be here on time you just keep
walking
that's not how shopping period works but
but it did in that class so the last
time I had the pleasure of introducing
general McChrystal he had recently
arrived on campus and the title of his
talk then if memory serves was plywood
leadership and that was a bit over two
years ago and I'll admit I wasn't too
sure how this was all gonna work out
okay he probably knew it would be great
but but I'll confess I wasn't I wasn't
sure at the time I am pretty sure that
it was probably the first time in the
300 plus year history of Yale that an
officer of general McChrystal's rank
moved within a matter of weeks from
commanding a war in the battlefield to
the classroom and the rest as they say
is history
what is that history well general
McChrystal teaches a seminar on
leadership that's probably one of the
most popular courses here on campus we
get hundreds of enquiries for the some
20 some slots a very keen I will notice
on the sidelines of football games now
general McChrystal is there hopefully
not calling the play providing
inspiration perhaps he's been
instrumental in bringing other key
people here to Yale some of whom in fact
are here in the room
and he's offered career advice and even
jobs Sam I'm talking about you to a
number of Yale students over the years
again some of them are here today so for
all of those things thank you we're
deeply deeply grateful it's really neat
this time to introduce stan mcchrystal
really as a member of the Yale community
the format
that Jim was going to explain the format
but there is no formal format so we can
do whatever we want in here what I would
like to do is thank you for coming here
today there's some special friends old
friends who've been here that I've spent
a lot of time with it kind of in combat
some friends I spent two years writing a
book with there's one friend I spent 35
years married to special friends and and
I just want to thank you because what
I'm gonna do today is just throw out
some thoughts and then at the end of it
we can talk about whatever you want any
any question is okay as is any answer
that I might give so what I thought I'd
do is I I thought we'd talk about
history leadership and personal
experience because everybody's had some
but as you think about it you break
those down those are sort of the three
themes that I think about when I try to
put my life in perspective and I think
all of us go through a point when you
put your life in your perspective and
you decide what was important what
wasn't important them what maybe did you
learn along the way I start back this is
the day I graduated from West Point West
Point is about trying to take somebody
and make them a better person it's about
recruiting talent and making it better
as you can see that day I recruited
talent I don't know that I made it
better but that was starting out of life
I'd grown up in an army family my father
was a soldier my father's father was a
soldier my four brothers were all
soldiers my sister married a soldier
Annie's father was a career soldier her
three brothers her soldiers her sisters
the widow of a soldier so you kind of
get it it was going into a family
business that was very comfortable and
it was my sense of trying to be like my
father which drove me because he was the
guy that I admired and I still admire
him to this day
but you know I entered the United States
Military Academy in 1972 the military
was going through a tough period as many
of the people in this room remember we
brag in the class of 76 when we
graduated four years later that we
entered in the easiest year in the
Academy's history to be accepted into
West Point because there just wasn't
that much popularity to it and the army
in fact was a shambles drug uses problem
with integrity just staggering out of a
war in Vietnam that not only tore the
nation apart but it actually tore the
American army apart the things which had
marked the army before professionalism
dedication to duty were all under
question so the army that my peers and I
entered in the summer of 1976 was one
that was still badly damaged and had
great self-doubt about itself and so
much of my career entering this army was
effected by watching it change watching
it grow watching it heal and watching it
move forward and become something very
different if you look at this picture
and you see in the top left hand corner
this is when I was a young captain it
was at Fort Stewart Georgia this is the
early 1980s and the guy in the top
left-hand picture our corner of the
picture may be familiar to you
his name was general Norman Schwarzkopf
Stormin Norman and he could I was in
meetings with him where he would erupt
and of course everybody would head for
the exits but he cared about soldiers
one day there was the golf course was
right near the parade field and there
were some guys out playing golf and at
the end of the day they started to play
retreat and on a military base when
retreat starts to play you come first to
parade rest and then to attention as the
flags being lowered and there were some
guys who saw fit to keep playing golf
bad plan but that was the kind of guy
was but I show you this picture to tell
you that my experience
with leadership although I knew general
Schwarzkopf as well as a captain knows a
two-star general at the time was really
the guy in the rain jacket in the center
and his name was Pierce
t grainy or tom grainy and he was my
battalion commander might when I went to
take I wanted to be an infantry company
commander very very badly and I went up
to run this 50-mile race that they do
once a year near Harpers Ferry Virginia
and so the day before I'm gonna go up
and run this thing and I've been
training with some other guys they've
called me in and they said you're gonna
go down next Monday and take command of
a company and of course for a young
infant room that's the goal and I said
well I'm gonna run this thing on Sunday
how about Tuesday and they said no
problem so I show up Tuesday morning to
this battalion to take command of a
company and the battalion commander has
been relieved his office is empty so I
go look for this battalion sergeant
major his office is empty the battalion
adjutant the personnel officer his
office is empty and it turns out four
people had been relieved to include the
company commander that I would have
placed and so I take command in this
battalion that was traumatized me
walking in I'm traumatized just by that
experience and three weeks later this
guy Tom grainy shows up and I had grown
up in a world of stereotyped military
leaders guys who stood very tall and
barked orders lived a certain almost two
dimensional existence and in comes Tom
grainy and he was a little bit punchy
you really can't see this he didn't much
like physical training he told us in a
meeting one day because we did physical
training at 6:30 he says I want every
soldier in this battalion and PT
formation at 6:30 every morning because
when I go back to bed I want to know
where you are
he smoked like a chimney drank quite a
lot and he led by sarcasm
every time you thought you'd done
something well instead of saying good
job he would make some cutting sarcastic
comment and so he sort of violated
everything we think about his
traditional leadership except two things
he really knew his business he knew how
to make an organization work and it
cared and it was obvious and so he
started this change in the organization
and we were very mediocre talent of all
the battalions in the division we
probably were the most mediocre on
average of any but he started making us
good by making us work together and it
was extraordinary he did some
interesting things one day says we're
not going to have lunch anymore what do
you mean not lunch but his point was if
we worked through the lunch period we
could let the soldiers off earlier and
they could go do all those things they
wanted to do over the lunch hour earlier
and they actually got more time off and
it made a lot of sense but it was very
non-standard right he got upset about it
and then one day I was became his
operations officer and he taught me
something that was really important
vehicles were coming back in from the
field one of our companies were coming
back in from fee like a column of
armored vehicles and it had to stop to
cross this road well you had a public
highway to stop and check it out and so
they called him for permission to cross
the road and I'm in the back of his Jeep
his operations officers are and they
called him non-secure because we had the
ability to secure our radios those days
but it was very clunky system it was a
thing called immense and you hooked it
into your radio and sometimes it worked
and sometimes it didn't and so they
called him non-secure and they said you
know we want to cross the road he said
no call me secure and ask me and they
said well you know our stuffs not
working you know how this stuff is how
about we just crossed it and we'll fix
it when we get to garrison this is
Friday afternoon and they wanted the
weekend off and he said no call me
secure we'll wait so here I am captain
McChrystal sit in the back of his Jeep
thinking we are going to be here til
Sunday night
this is going to be ugly and what
happens is suddenly after about two more
entreaties from them he they they
suddenly start to scurry outside their
armored vehicles and they start taking
antennas off one vehicle going in and
getting a cable off another pulling a
Vincent device on another and they start
all this activity and they're obviously
taking pieces and cobbling together a
working system and in about 20 minutes
they call and they call secured and it
was an interesting lesson for me because
he said there you go and the lesson was
what you demand the standard you demand
is the standard you'll get and the
standard you accept is the standard
you'll get and it became an
extraordinary lesson for me in a leader
who doesn't necessarily look or feel
exactly like you think a leader ought to
but he was one of the best and had a
bigger impact on me than probably anyone
else in my development some years later
I went to got older commanded a bunch of
places up through the first Gulf War and
whatnot and then I was put in command of
an organization called Joint Special
Operations Command and that is America's
counter-terrorist forces you're aware of
the components of most of those and we
were fighting in a number of areas but
the biggest fight we were in was in Iraq
and Iraq was difficult as you know the
initial invasion of Iraq looked pretty
easy to people within a few months it
looked like it was going to be very
difficult and I took over this command
in the fall of 2003 with the mission to
fight against al-qaeda in Iraq which was
led by a guy named Abu Musab al-zarqawi
and so I take command of this
organization in Iraq looks a little bit
like this picture this is the golden
Mosque that was blown up in 2006 by
Sunnis to incite Shia outrage but really
a lot of Iraq looked like a lot of this
for a long time
and yet here I am on 911 I'm a 46 year
old brigadier general and the thing
about being a 46 year old brigadier
general is you don't want anything to
change because you've been in the
organization long enough to know where
things are how things operate you've
sort of mastered the system so if
somebody changes the system your
relative comfort level and your
expertise is threatened and so suddenly
we're in a fight and this is me I look
like a soldier I act like a soldier I
know my business I feel very comfortable
about that I've got a certain amount of
credibility and so this is the guy who
doesn't want to change because why would
I life's good and then this guy comes
into my life born in October 1966 and he
became known as Abu Musab al-zarqawi
that was a cunha which means father of
Musab from the village of Zarqa he was a
young Jordanian who had grown up in a
very lower middle class or upper lower
class family as kind of a tough had
troubles of his youth but wasn't
terrible then got into drugs got into
alcohol got into a number of scrapes
with the law got himself thrown into
prison and when he got thrown into
prison he hooked up with a guy named
Mike Deasy who was a cleric and he
became much more ideologically focused
he left prison went to Afghanistan where
the tail end of the Mujahideen period
was ongoing and he became allied or
affiliated with al-qaeda and he started
to grow into a serious leader so
suddenly you've got Stan McChrystal
leader military officer and Abu Saud al
Zarqawi he's never been a military
officer never held an official position
but suddenly he's a leader and when you
think of a terrorist you think of a guy
who blows stuff up and causes things to
happen
which he did starting in the summer of
2003 in Iraq and then in early 2004 when
we knew he had already started to create
this Network and we had to destroy it we
captured a video we'd had a young man
missing who was an American named Nick
Berg and Nick Berg was wandering around
Iraq looking for work which wasn't a
smart thing to do at the time but he'd
gotten himself taken hostage and passed
to al-qaeda we did quite an effort to
try to find him but that was also the
time when Fallujah in other areas were
exploding and then we heard word that
he'd been killed and very soon after
that we intercepted a copy of a video
and they brought it into my office
to show it to me on a laptop computer
and they said sir you need to see this
and I stood there and they put the
laptop and a friend of mine and there
were six guys in black outfits with
black hoods over their heads and a young
man sitting cross-legged on in front of
them in an orange jumpsuit which was
similar to what we had detainees wearing
in the larger prisons and whatnot
detainee camps in Iraq and they talked
for a while with him in front of him and
then at a critical moment the individual
right behind him pulled out of his cloak
a large knife a huge bowie light knife
and he cut Nick Berg's head off on the
video and I remember standing there
watching it and we'd been fighting I'd
now been leading this force for about
six months and it had been a difficult
bloody fight already but I remember at
the end of it I had to physically
unclench my fists because I was that
outraged and I was that angry but the
temptation to make this guy a
two-dimensional character is one you
couldn't fall prey to because he wasn't
a two-dimensional character instead of
being central casting terrorists here
was a guy who dressed the part and he
liked to look that part as a fighter but
he also went around and when he met
with different parts of the organization
he would come in and he'd sit down and
he'd listened patiently he drink tea
with him he would show deference to
local parts of the insurgency because
all insurgencies and terrorist networks
are groupings of local entities then he
would give out audio recordings and one
night were sitting there listening to an
audio recording and he's talking about
to the brave lions of so-and-so to the
stalwart heroes of so-and-so and
basically what he was doing is going by
Township and one of our officers goes
Holy Smoke
this guy is motivating each of these
individual groups by mentioning them
publicly just like a leader in a
corporation or a political leader in
America might do reaching down to their
sense of worth to their ego to their
commitment and creating commitment to
something that we've considered
absolutely evil but was extraordinarily
powerful so through a combination of
personal example a little bit of
religion in there but in reality was
much more political movement than
anything religious and some basic
leadership he pulled together a network
that leveraged Sunni fear because at
that point in Iraq the Sunnis were
terrified of a post-saddam world in
which a Shia plurality in fact would
would dominate and he leveraged their
fears and caused them to take part in
terrorist activities that were
extraordinarily bloody the number of
people whose deaths he caused was
staggering and when we hit the very
difficult years 2006-2007 the numbers
exploded even more we finally in the
spring of 2006 were able to tighten the
neuter noose around a boom Musab
al-zarqawi we were able to capture a
group of individuals of whom one turned
out to be aware of who is per
gentle spiritual advisor was so this
individual after a number of weeks in
confinement with us and no mistreatment
just long conversations along patient
conversations he finally said I can tell
you who his spiritual advisor is and we
were able from that then over several
more weeks to track his spiritual
adviser every day until finally we were
able to follow him using a variety of
assets follow him to Abu Musab markets
our College location and we were able to
strike and kill him
but at that point he'd already lit the
fuse his goal was to create a civil war
in Iraq and essentially he'd done that
that was June of 2006 this the
destruction you saw earlier of the
golden mosque happened earlier that
spring and there was sectarian fighting
that continued really for two more years
you still see vestiges of it now the
thing that changed so much for me though
as you fight a guy who's that effective
and I'm taking an organization that was
insular I'd grown up with the special
operations where where you took great
pride in operational security you took
great pride in being part of a special
organization and this was an
organization a little bit like a
football team big shoulders big knuckles
brave guys but people who didn't look
like football players weren't
necessarily invited into that culture
and so as a consequence the organization
I took had a little exclusivity that
unfortunately excluded a lot of what we
needed we excluded some of the talent
and intelligence talent and
communications talent and cultural
acuity and we had to get over it and it
took us a year or so to do that we had
to lose the war for a while until people
backed off and said we're not going to
win unless we change and the first
person who had to change was the guy on
the left because remember I'm feeling
good about myself but you don't feel
good when you're leading a losing effort
so really over 2004 and 2005 I had to go
from a centralized organization where I
was the man to pushing it down to
decentralized where other
people actually made the decisions I had
to go from an organization where
information would flow up to me and then
as the font of all wisdom I would give
guidance to or what I did was create an
environment in which other people
figured it out and did it you have to
step away from your ego a little bit I
did and it caused us to be go from being
a more stove-piped organization to being
a flattened organization where
information flowed and I didn't direct
things so much as I encouraged things
and it was an amazing change because we
started the war we had our heroes and
everybody's a hero in the organization
when we started and you just kind of
wouldn't deal with people who weren't
heroes like us to a year or two later
and I'd go into a room and there'd be a
plywood table and you'd see a big hook
and look an operator II to have a beard
and you know scars and I'll listen
across the table there'd be a 90 pound
young female Intel analyst and she'd
have her finger like that telling him
what the deal was and he's listening
really big change and really important
change because you started to be valued
on your contribution to the overall
effort not on your personal batting
average or not on what you look like or
what you thought of yourself biggest
change in my career and yet it started
late hard to accept when it first starts
and then when you start to work than you
I guess you get over it and you start to
move my last assignment was Afghanistan
I'd actually gone to Afghanistan in the
spring of 2002 I'd gone right after
ambassador Crocker had been there and
Afghanistan was literally this is
probably the best place in Afghanistan
in that's a nicest place you got that
this the country was physically torn to
pieces even beyond that it was torn in
ways that weren't obvious sort of like a
collective abused abandoned child
Afghanistan had been through about 23
years of war already when I arrived in
2002
and so the fabric of society had been
ripped those people who had been
traditional leaders in Afghanistan had
lost their standing and those people who
had fought as part of the Mujahideen or
during the Civil War many cases had
gathered for themselves political power
economic power social power and suddenly
you had these what we call non-standard
leaders or warlords as dominant figures
in the country it's sort of a
post-apocalyptic place in which press a
button that normally produces a certain
outcome and you have no idea people
would come and I'd say we don't
understand Afghanistan and I'd say
either do the Afghans the last time
normal had been in Afghanistan was 1978
and earlier everything since then wasn't
and so everybody was trying to navigate
where it went and that was 2002 and I
was there part of every year after that
with special operating forces then I got
there in the summer 2009 and now what
had happened as we'd arrived in 2001 and
Afghans had been very happy about that
we pushed al-qaeda out we'd up into the
Taliban government and they'd had great
expectations for what the future was
going to be finally America and the West
was going to help them they were gonna
have a better more stable future greater
economic opportunity but a gap had come
between what they expected or what they
desired and what they got and that gap
grew and as that gap grew cynicism grew
the Taliban found an opportunity to
start to come back in exploit some of
the fissures we made a lot of mistakes
because we didn't understand we didn't
speak the language we didn't understand
the culture we elide with some people we
shouldn't have and so as a consequence
when I got there in 2009 the situation
was getting worse and confidence was the
biggest problem people were always
worried about the future no matter what
progress you made they'd look onto the
future they'd say yeah but you're about
to leave and things are about to go bad
and we were in a place where America was
already tired of war
and Afghans were tired of war and one of
the things we had to deal with it damage
like this could have been caused by an
allied or American airstrike and we say
well we'll fighting your enemy we're
fighting to liberate you so we're going
to do this airstrike and if we hit
something like a house or something like
that that happens but if you go back
into the Afghan mindset in 2001 they saw
us arrive with incredible precision in
our intelligence and incredible
precision and our strikes and we up into
the Taliban in a matter of weeks helped
them up into Taliban then after that
whenever they saw something they would
say ok wait a minute
we say well we made a mistake we hit
Afghan civilians sorry and they go wait
a minute you are omniscient because
you've got such great intelligence and
you're omnipotent because you hit what
you want to hit so one or two things is
true either you tried to hit those
civilians or you really don't care
you're just careless and they started to
draw conclusions that said when you come
in to liberate us that's not the best
outcome for us if we are killed in the
process that's not better than being in
a position under Taliban rule because an
Afghan if you ask them a rural
Afghanistan what they'd like and you
said would you like us to win the
government to win they go yeah that
would be best but we're not sure you're
gonna do it how would you like the
Taliban to when they say well actually
that'd be our second choice the choice
we can't live with his war in the front
yard we can't live with us being killed
in the process of being liberated and so
we had to make a change in the way we
approach the war to convince the Afghan
people that they were our reason for
being there that protecting them was our
responsibility our charge our passion
and yet we're in America tired of war
and so suddenly you've got this tension
you got a certain part of America and
remember inside the military you're
created a fight so you kind of want to
do that you're in this position where
you've got to convince the force we
can't do that what we've really got to
do is accept greater risk to ourselves
to try to reduce violence protect the
Afghan people and win their support and
you talk to a young sergeant who's got
every right in the world he's just
driven through a village where
improvised explosive devices have gone
off and the population obviously knew
they were there and didn't tell him and
you say he says you want me to protect
these people but they're trying to kill
me and the reality is yeah because
that's the only road to success that's
the only road to victory during the
1980s the Afghans lost 1.2 million
people killed when the Soviet war was
there you're not going to kill enough
Afghans to win you're only going to win
when the Afghans believe that their
government is the best option for them
so we had to try to change the mindset
of our force and we had to build
relationships with people you don't
normally build relationships with or
you're not comfortable I mean who do you
hang out with when you have spare time
who's a soldier feel comfortable hanging
out with other soldiers you feel
comfortable with people who look like
you speak your language have your
background and whatnot and you build
relationships of trust and we talk about
camaraderie Band of Brothers and whatnot
but the brothers are all pretty damn
similar but suddenly you're asking to go
into a complex environment and you're
betting that's me sort of in the center
President Karzai slightly to the left in
us down in Conda haar having one of
these sure is and we had a whole bunch
of these things and just trying to talk
through what we're going to do he's
trying to convince local leaders this
would be the equivalent of President
Obama coming to a any state getting
local mayors and whatnot together and
explaining to him what he's going to do
in this case this is
President Karzai saying he's gonna
change the Second Amendment and take
everybody's guns away it's about that
popular and so he's sitting down trying
to build relationships and that's what
we had to do my comfort zone would be
fighting but where you end up as a
leader is somewhere different and if you
look at it
he's got me to his left which is a gutsy
move because with me sitting so close to
him we say well look you know America
supported him and all this kind of stuff
it's obvious he's trying to use it but
that's for him that's politically
difficult because it makes him - those
people look like a potential puppet but
he makes the call I'm gonna put him
right there and I'm gonna take the heat
for it and it's under it's important we
understand that because it's a very
different environment than we might
think generally so I had to change here
I had to build relationships with people
that weren't the ones I would naturally
build relationships with and yet if you
don't build relationships you never
accomplished anything okay this is one
of the places I ended up in the last
year of my career
I don't think anybody starts your career
thinking you're going to end up
conversing with presidents or in the
Oval Office or speaking to NATO
headquarters or doing any of the things
that many of us and many of you in this
room have done or will do you just don't
you're not wired to expect that that's
going to happen in many cases when you
go forward into these things it's the
first time you've ever done it a lot of
people in the room walk into there and
they try to act nonchalant but in
reality they have been in a meeting like
that before
and it's an extraordinary experience
it's a great responsibility but it's an
extraordinary experience because
suddenly you're being what you read
about suddenly you're taking part in
events that are going to be written
about but you really didn't have time to
think about it they are suddenly upon
you
you're amongst these decisions and
events and you're doing what feels right
at the time and doing it with as much
apparent self-confidence and comfort as
you can and everybody in the rooms that
way and that's of course a good thing to
remember some people are better actors
about it but everybody's then they're
thinking holy [ __ ] I'm trying to be
something that I really am not they're
gonna figure me out and they're gonna
toss me out of this room in a few
minutes but that's the experience and
when I talk to the young people in the
room what I'd say is you're going to
travel this and you're never gonna feel
completely prepared you're never going
to feel like you were raised to be King
and suddenly you're King you're raised
to be whatever it is you are but
suddenly you're going to be there and
what shouldn't desert you is what's
inside what shouldn't desert you are
your values that's the one thing that
nobody can can push if you don't let
them push that's your understanding of
what you believe in and what's right and
wrong it's the most important thing you
walk out of a place like Yale with I'm
gonna stop there and open it for any
questions that you might have thank you
all right I'm gonna bring the mic out
and we can gentleman right here pray
tell what is going to be our experience
in the Middle East the whole area which
seems to be coming apart you know so
many different scenes you can hardly
count them hey sorry his is America to
be involved in all this yes sir and the
question was what's going to be our
experience in the Middle East it's been
pretty hairy for the last 10 years and
it's going to be more so and we are
going to be involved whether we want to
or not that is not a choice not just
because of oil because increasingly
America will be energy independent but
the world won't and we're not going to
be independent of the fact the world as
a fabric knitted together now if you
look at what's happening in the Mideast
my view of it is we've gotten ourselves
a little bit narrowly focused on certain
events that happened what happened in
Algeria last week what's happening in
Mali what happened in Egypt a couple of
years ago and continues to play out but
I think there are several things that
are occurring one is following the 1967
arab-israeli war pan Arab nationalism
was discredited to a large degree an
extremist Islam as one of the things
that would occur got new power and then
there were some autocratic regimes as
you saw Colonel Qaddafi President
Mubarak and others across the region
sort of put a lid on a pressure cooker
but the pressure continued to build
starting with the the beginning of the
Arab Spring in Tunisia you started in my
view the movement of some tectonic
plates and they are moving and nobody's
quite sure where they're gonna go they
are not gonna automatically go to
Western democracy they're not
automatically going to go to chaos
they're not automatically going to go to
the Muslim Brotherhood but they're
moving and they will keep moving for a
while and there going to be some things
caught in between those and broken I
think some of the big themes will be
first the rise of the Muslim Brotherhood
so goes Egypt goat so goes the popular
opinion of much of the region and as
Egypt has a Muslim Brotherhood
leadership depending how they go I think
it's very possible
the Muslim Brotherhood Jordan and other
areas will be increasingly influential
they may not run the whole area but they
will be in an influential part pressure
that moves the other thing that that is
absolute is the sunni-shia friction
point and that's you're seeing that play
out in Syria of course we seen it we saw
it up close play out in Iraq and will
continue to pull out and I think that's
going to last for quite a while I think
as the Sunni Gulf states particularly
pump arms and other things into that
fight as Iran supports the Shia side
you're going to have this fault line
that creates heat and friction and I
think it's very likely that it areas
like Lebanon of course Syria to me it's
very very unclear where Syria goes and
of course Israel's caught in the middle
of all this without being the dominant
player in the region by any means
they're going to be in my mind affected
by this more than they affected I would
worry about the stability of some of the
regimes even in the Gulf the ones we've
taken for granted for several
generations like Saudi Arabia but I have
a certain humility Ryan what have I
gotten wrong yeah ambassador Crocker who
taught me a lot of the region I has much
more background but we are not going to
back away from it we are not going to
turn our back and if we do it'll tap us
on the shoulder and and jump on our
heads questions from the bank
general McChrystal what do you think of
the Pentagon's decision today to open
the front lines to woman yeah I mean
they're already in the front lines they
already fly combat aircraft they already
your military police they're already in
local firefights I think that is
recognizing a reality that's been for a
while now with opportunity comes
responsibility because in so much as you
offer the opportunity to be in direct
combat to females you don't offer it to
just those who feel like being in direct
combat you really kind of open the door
for any female now it can be put good
needs of the army can be put in
situations they may not I don't know
exactly how the Army's going to handle
that part but I think it's a significant
change there going to be a few cultural
things to get over but I think it's a
natural evolution and what
kind of see where it takes us I think if
we if we don't admit that reality in the
near term we're sort of kidding
ourselves and the ones that I saw fight
fight real well so no worrys questions
from front thank you very much if this
is a very from a very selfish point of
view based on your personal experience
not only me but a lot of people would
like to see you have a broader role in
the future so what are your plans my
plan is to continue teaching at the
Jackson Institute until Jim fires me
yeah I I'm really passionate about
leadership right now and there are
several issues leadership in general
national service sort of the latest drum
I want to bang for a while is the idea
of national service for every young
American you notice all the old people
clapping
yeah I mean I'm old now so hey I'm all
about that no I really believe that
every young person needs to do a year or
two of national service not just
military but costs because two reasons
one if you don't invest in something you
don't value it the same as I tell people
if I tell you to pick up trash or
chopper Street every day you feel more
about littering you feel more strongly
about littering that's a bad analogy for
a country but it is one the other thing
is we've got parts of America that never
meet other parts of America when we've
got parts of our society that just don't
interact with other parts of and that's
a bad bad thing and I think national
service could force that in ways that
would be very valuable in the future and
if everybody had to do it with zero
exemptions then I think people wouldn't
be too upset about it they just do it
and move on with life if it was unfair
it'd be a disaster so that that's what I
wanted to sir thank you question from
the back good afternoon
general McChrystal's good to see you
again last semester when I had you in
class we were talking a lot about
communication and its importance in
leadership and you were also talking
about how in your experience you never
feel fully prepared but I'm sure that a
lot of preparation goes into your
communication when you're going to meet
with a president or speak to those who
your command and so I was wondering what
process do you go through when you're
preparing a presentation or I'm getting
ready to meet with important officials
that's actually a great question the
first thing to understand is who you're
communicating with and what you want to
communicate and that sounds that sounds
obvious but it's not always sometimes we
we have this message that we want to put
out and we're so interested in saying it
the way we want to say it that we sort
of can it that way and then we shoot it
and in reality
somebody's receiving it and the people
who are receiving it you got to
understand that we used to have prepare
slides for the president when I was on
the Joint Staff and you could only put I
think three bullets on the slide no
bullet could be more than a certain
number of words we called it pota sizing
the slides
but the reason is here's a guy who's
getting 8000 briefings a day from it's
the most important issue to me may not
be number one on the President's List so
the first thing I got to understand is
what am I trying to get him to walk away
with and you can absolutely kill your
message if you dilute it too much if you
try to give more than they can take or
if you get personal sort of emotion into
it if you get in there and you're
screaming and banging on stuff pretty
soon people die it works like once and
then everybody dials you out from there
and then it does help to know what
you're talking about you know that's not
always good and you in the US government
cuz what happens is somebody down low
knows what they're talking about and
they prepare a brief and they send it up
or a position paper and it goes through
eight levels and by the time it gets to
someone senior who's going to go brief
the great man or woman that person
really doesn't know much so you got a
conversation between two people who
really don't know much and then once
they get beyond the real superficial
part it's hard for them to go further so
I'm a great fan of taking the person who
actually knows a lot and you may need to
bring them along with you but say here's
the dude actually knows what he's
talking about what do you wanna know and
and I find that that works plus it
motivates junior people because they get
to they get to give the information
straight my son's in the Intel community
now and he's down here and so he's the
guy making the slide that gets corrected
eight times before it goes up pretty
interesting to get his perspective
generally crystal you mentioned earlier
that towards the end of our time in
Afghanistan that America is a nation in
many ways was tired of spending of
spending in of war and so I wondered how
reminiscent in your study of history was
that of the Vietnam army and what do you
think made our army successful in the
end and what can we take from that and
continue forward in their success yeah
it's interesting because the comparison
I'm talking about the army now in in
marine cores while wrapped together in
Vietnam and and compared to Afghanistan
there's several things that were done
very differently one in the Vietnam War
we made some personnel decisions which
were disastrous one of them was we
rotated individuals and so an individual
goes and he stays 12 months or she stays
12 months and then they come home so the
unit is always in constant turmoil we
didn't change commanders every six or 12
months we changed him every six months
so a commander comes in he takes over
and in six months he's gone so you've
got this turnstile effect and so what
happened was in Vietnam we took the
force and we didn't use the reserves
which we considered doing instead we
grounded so usually an army that's at
war gains combat experience and you're
on the one hand you're gaining
experience on the other hand you're
trading the force are wearing it down so
the question is do they do they balance
each other out in Vietnam we kill
ourselves because we first did the
individuals so we didn't keep building
combat experience so we didn't get that
benefit but we ground on the army to
nothing
so by 1969 the army was weaker and less
professional than it had been in 1966
and yet you think in three years of war
we should have been really good at it
we were worse and we had less experience
in the field in Afghanistan and Iraq we
did a few things smart we rotated by
units we prepared unit we rotated by
unit they stayed together there was a
sense of teamwork that's easier to
maintain now we didn't have the same
casualties level as they did in
Afghanistan I mean in Vietnam so it
wasn't quite the same but it
was we hit we've had kids who've been at
war in combat for five years six years
and yet the military son together so
we've done much better at our personnel
management what worries me now is the
military is too insulated from society
in the Civil War one out of every 68
Americans was wounded in combat so that
means now wounded not just served
someone in your family or your town was
wounded and you saw now it's one out of
every seven thousand two hundred and
ninety three most Americans never see a
wounded soldier
most don't really know a service member
they may know a friend of a friend who's
got a nephew who's a service member but
you you were wonderful to them we thank
them in airports we buy meals but we
don't know him and so that connection is
not as tight as I would like it to be so
I think that's another thing that
strengthens militaries - it's a sense
that you are you are a connection with
the populace if you think that people
don't care about the war don't believe
in the war it's a lot harder to fight
the war particularly when people are
saying it's an utter waste of time oh
yeah thanks for your service Wow it's a
tough thing and it's only the cohesion
and forces I think that can help make up
for that question in the front I can't
help but ask you based on your insights
into leadership in general what has
happened to political leadership in the
United States of America
I thought you can ask me any economic
questions to you I was all prepared to
tell you about gross national whatever
it is yeah I'm a great believer that
people act rationally and it's very hard
there were some who don't I know a few
but most people act rationally and if we
look at what's rewarded we'll see why
they act that way and that's true of
terrorists that's true of people in
Afghanistan just figure it out what we
have now is individual rationality and
collective irrationality if we look at
political leaders in America
what are they rewarded for they are
rewarded for holding to a position which
typically is more extreme left or more
extreme right then we might like because
we gerrymandered so many congressional
districts we've created so many things
so if you stick to that you are rewarded
if you move to the center and compromise
you're punished individually you aren't
reelected or you're punished in other
ways so what happens is they're acting
rationally because each of them is
protecting their political position
their political base and what not and
yet collectively it's irrational because
we're like lemmings going off this cliff
and we haven't found a way to say wait a
minute
we're gonna hold it individuals
responsible for this collective failure
and the more you finger point and
criticize the more credit you get
there's a there was a interesting
phenomenon they used to say that before
the the last the invasion of Iraq that
Saddam Hussein used to get credit for
what he said not just what he did so
he'd stand up and in their culture he'd
say the US was threatening me says I'm
gonna kick their rear end and we
considered that ridiculous he's making a
fool of himself it wasn't completely
viewed that way in his society they were
going well he gets partial credit for
saying he's gonna do it even if it never
did never does it we kind of a back down
to that in our political world you know
if we criticize someone else somehow we
get plus points and I think it's I think
it's the the electorate's responsibility
to fix it but we haven't yet figured out
how to do that we we get so exercised
over small issues that the big ones that
mean are our kids going to get educated
and they're going to have you know a
secure country they can have a future we
don't seem to put that as high on the
the list as other things I'm that
passionate I should shut up they're
sarsti
questions from the bank
sir I'd like to thank you for personally
inviting the Yale cadets this evening
being a junior Yale cadet myself I'm
going to graduate and commissioned as a
second lieutenant in the United States
Air Force soon so my question is for
those young officers out there what
advice would you give them yeah it's
great and thanks for doing that I think
you're gonna really enjoy it and learn a
lot I think the first thing is when you
go out to be a junior leader the first
thing you want to be is technically
competent and powerful as a leader you
want to walk in and you want to be the
guy with the answer is you want to be
the guy who can make decisions that's
not really the most important thing when
you first go out there if you go out
there and you're willing to listen
you're willing to empathize with your
troops notice I didn't say sympathize
I said try to understand them if you are
willing to learn they'll do anything for
you they will absolutely because they
don't expect you to be an expert they
expect you to be a mature guy who cares
and learns quickly because they expect
you to learn really Qwest be effective
the most ineffective officers I've ever
seen knew it all the day they walked in
even if they didn't know a lot they were
actually the most effective were the
ones who came in and said okay help me
figure this out then it becomes a team
effort
they are vested in your success they
want you to succeed and they're going to
make sure the LT is squared away and I
learned that more and more throughout my
career you know that the higher I got
the more I did less and less because
other people could and would do it for
me it's kind of the tom sawyer theater
or the theory of leadership but you know
that's really what you want because it's
not how powerful you are
it's how effective the organization is
that's your metric of success not your
personal power and it just takes a
little while for some people to sort of
figure that one out good luck
picking up on the idea of communication
that's been talked about a little bit
you mentioned in your talk about when
you arrive in the Middle East and the
military not knowing the language with
communication and you talked about
connecting with the populace as well I
can't imagine a more important factor in
going to another place whether it's the
military going there or am I going there
as a tourist of being able to
communicate and connect with the
populace how did that not knowing the
language while you were there change if
it did and where are we now
whether it's connecting with a populist
in the Middle East Africa Southeast Asia
could you speak to that place yes sir I
sure can
let me first describe personal
experience on that I would go on raids
with my force and these are nighttime
raids and you put on your battle dress
uniform you put on body armor put on
your helmet you carry a m4 assault
carbine you got all this stuff on and
you have protective glasses on you hit a
target and typically you're going after
a person but there may be families in
there and of course you don't harm them
but you go in this house people are
upset imagine people who are more than
six feet tall they look huge in all this
equipment we look like space invaders
and we're in their living room at 2:00
in the morning in a society that doesn't
like invasions of privacy not that ours
would either but you start there they're
talking suddenly I can't understand a
word it's white noise I'm talking to
members of my force to them it's white
noise we might have a translator with us
or two typically a hired translator but
every time you put something through a
translator there's a filter and they
can't be everyplace
so as you're stand-in there you're
moving to deal with people and you may
be moving females here or talking to
somebody you're this menacing thing that
has no way to connect with them we went
in with
so little language skill it was terrible
and I would tell you in my personal
opinion we've still got so little
language skill it's terrible and we have
handicapped our performance dramatically
because you know if you can talk to
somebody at a certain while you realize
they're not that bad but if you can't if
you just see them from afar those guys
it's half the problem we need you know I
came to the conclusion I came to this
conclusion after the fact that after
9/11 what I think we should have done is
sent 10,000 young Americans to language
school and then 10,000 the next year
dari Pashto Arabic other language
because not just military but others
because if you can't you can't sort a
problem out unless you can communicate
and we are just terrible at it and the
military is terrible at it now go on
record it that we we are hesitant to put
people in a long language school because
it's a diversion from what they're doing
it's a distraction I said nothing's
gonna distract us like losing this war
so you know yeah you hit you hit
something that I think is utterly
critical I don't think anybody should
graduate from college without being
fluent in at least one foreign language
so anyway that's what I think question
from the bank
my good sir
no Coast Guard questions general
mcchrystal thank you for coming her for
being here in the realm of national
defense and international threats in the
future how you see America balancing our
projection power and overseas offenses
with I guess increased measures of
homeland security and a greater sense of
domestic defence yeah really the
question is how do you balance
protecting the homeland and doing what
you think you need to do forward some of
which is defending for it I don't think
you can defend America at the borders
one it's imperfect it's too hard to do
perfectly you can make it harder and one
of the things we have to do is come to
the realization there will be another
attack like 9/11 and just decide right
now we're not going to get freaked out
by it we're gonna not overreact we're
gonna move forward cuz somebody can do
that it's just not that hard we're going
to need to engage in the world though
one of the things I used to tell people
of Afghanistan you can't build enough
walls around your compound you can't
build an armored vehicle so strong and
you can't wear enough body armor to
protect you if the people want to kill
you your security ultimately comes from
the people in a local area has to they
see things they know things they stop
kids from joining they stop IEDs well it
I think that's true around the world as
well we look at what happened in Libya
people had a lot of talk today but one
of the realities is in every country we
rely typically upon the government to
provide local security for diplomats and
whatnot we have to the Libyans wouldn't
want us to put two battalions of Marines
in to protect our consulate it's just
not practical and it's not acceptable so
you've got to build relationships and
understandings to do that so I think the
reality is we have to make America more
secure but understand it's not going to
be perfectly secure and we've got to
make the world a place that we are
comfortable navigating again we're not
going to secure the world we're not
going to make everybody do what we want
but if we're not secure and navigating
it and comfortable in doing that we're
not going to see threats we're not going
to be able to convince people to to deal
with them as they grow and we're not
going to be able to shape the future to
reduce the number of threat
so just two in a time when America I
think a lot of us would kind of like to
withdraw back into our borders fix our
economy fix our schools let the world do
what its gonna do I don't think we can
do that
I think it's short-sighted from how much
room excuse me how much room in the
military is therefore critical thought
because a lot of what I think of the
military is very top-down yes sir no sir
how hi sir so how much room is there for
junior officers especially to make
changes it's even at like a local
battalion level yeah you hit something
really really important part of it is
the truth and part of it is the reality
and the to matter I mean the perception
and reality because the military is a
conservative organization that's
hierarchical you can't get away from
that you wear your rank overtly on your
uniform people can see they can see how
old you are they can see where you've
been they can see how senior you are so
there's a natural hesitation for people
to talk up in quite as brutally and
honest away as we need to senior leaders
are the people who have to change that
dynamic senior leaders have got to find
a way to make people feel comfortable
enough to talk up but not let it be
chaos I mean you can't let everybody
just you know act a fool so how do you
how do you create that balance one of
the things that I think and again it's
always a challenge in the military
because as leaders when you become
senior you know when you're young you'd
say I got to be able get the word up
when you're my age and somebody young
says you know Stan I think you're an
idiot your first response is thanks for
your feedback your first response is I'm
going to kick his ass
so you got to get over that and
everybody's got to get out what we did
in special ops was we try to create in
the CT world a meritocracy where people
could talk to regardless of your rank
based on you sort of proving credibility
over time but we were a limited
community that got to know each other
for a long time so it actually was much
easier for us to do that in the wider
military you're gonna have to create a
help create an environment where people
talk
other militant some other militaries do
it much better than us the British
military actually if you go to a Staff
College they'll have majors telling the
visiting general hey general Stan I
think I think you got it completely
wrong you completely screwed that up
and they'll do that and Americans are
much more hesitant to do that and then
their other militaries where they won't
say anything just tighter that fair it's
an absolute problem but it's not just a
military it's a problem in a lot of
organizations I don't think if you go on
Wall Street and you go up and tell the
CEO that he's an idiot that you're gonna
be wildly successful question in the
back
any more questions I've got a couple
right here
thank you I thought it might be safe now
to ask about the movies
I just saw zero dark thirty last night
and I noticed that you made a special
point when you were talking about
identifying your target in Iraq that you
got your information from detainees
through long conversations I'm not sure
if I read too much into that but I
assumed that might be a perspective that
you have on the use of torture and how
how successful that is gathering
information so first of all I'd love to
hear what you thought of the movie and
second of all I'm curious about the
detainee and the torture she's yeah I
did see the movie and I didn't stir
during the whole movie I didn't go get a
glass water didn't move because if it's
a very entertaining gripping movie no
doubt about it a few points first on
that the issue of torture I never saw
waterboarding I can't judge whether it
works or doesn't work I suspect that you
can get information out of people if
you're willing to torture them it may
not be perfect information but I know if
you tortured me I talk so you know I
just start with that assumption
the problem with torture is not that in
my view whether it works or doesn't work
the problem with torture is what it does
to the torturer if you start to torture
people you cross a line something in you
changes and if you're the individual
that does the torture you've created
unintentionally to walk back up if you
do it as an organizational position if
you the French in Algeria found
themselves this way they started to
accept torture and what they found was
it was eroding the professionalism and
the the moral values of the force so
what they found was they were in a
different position as people and as an
organisation than they wanted to be and
they also of course lost credibility
with their own public and with the
people in the area the worst thing that
ever happened and this was seared into
my mind in April of oh four pictures of
Abu Ghraib came out
now I had never had direct dealings with
a brute grave I was doing you know CT
stuff at the time the pictures came out
they were just unbelievable and they
were put in the papers as America did
this and we had a flood of foreign
fighters young men from North Africa
Syria Saudi Arabia come in as suicide
bombers and foreign fighters completely
motivated by the fact that they'd seen
these photographs which were to them
proof positive that that's American
policy we had heard America does this
here's the proof and they went and they
they made the war much much harder so to
me that was even though that wasn't
technical you know that torture and we
think it was mistreatment it had that
effect so I think it's extraordinary
that it to other parts of the movie I
thought were really good was they showed
it was a decade-long effort by a whole
bunch of people it wasn't just one
good-looking blonde lady that did it it
was really this huge group of people who
sacrificed and I was in Afghanistan
where the suicide bomber blew up it down
there host and those were pros trying to
make it happen just desperately trying
to perform for their nature and for
their nation and they died and then
finally the raid in my view was
stunningly realistic I mean it felt like
raids I'd been on I mean they didn't
over dramatize that nobody dode through
windows and threw a hand-grenade over
their head it was methodical and that's
the way it is and so I thought that part
was really faithful in tone I don't know
about to that perfect specific rate
thank you sir
I was just wondering if you could
comment you know you mentioned during
her time at JSOC you were bringing in
other parties bringing an expertise from
the Intel community from other
communities once you have those other
constituencies assembled you know they
they don't automatically all function as
one team so how do you make that final
step of you know you've got all the
parties together how do you make them
act sort of together as one you know
have those conversations where the Intel
person is sort of telling someone else
advice so
through my class last spring most people
did so don't worry about it
here's what you get you asked when
you're gonna form something for multi
organizational entity a task force or
Joint Task Force since we are creating
you ask all the different Intel agencies
and different military units to provide
people and what happens is if their
leadership isn't really focused what do
you get you get the people that are
expendable you know so-and-so is not
working - you go over and join that task
force because that's all right
some organizations don't do that some
organizations send superstars but you
first deal with the fact you get really
uneven Talent and then some of that
talent comes with instructions from
their headquarters don't cooperate they
say be part of it but don't give away
any of our organizational equities don't
tell any of our secrets don't whatever
so you got to first go up to the people
they bring and you got to make them
convinced that this is a very important
incredible thing and you share
information with everybody my
organization we had a lot of good
information that they didn't have and
what we did was we shared it all we said
here it is you you guys can have access
to everything now share with us so that
was part of it and that for about the
first year day year-and-a-half you know
we made progress slow and steady but for
two years as we did our video
teleconference we had one organization
that every day their rep you'd go to
them and you go what do you got and the
guy would go nothing from here today two
years now about a year later they
started you know actually getting but it
takes a long time the next thing we did
was we went to their senior directors
director of the different organizations
head of the FBI had a and whatnot and I
tried to establish personal
relationships with them and treat them
like stockholders or or board of
directors for our task force and I
talked about our task force which was
seven one four and I said we're your
task force we have a hundred and some
people from the CIA we have 90 people
from FBI we have this this this it's not
my task force I'm in charge here but you
all the owners of this thing
and so every month we had a video
teleconference with them and we reported
back what was happening we said this is
what your team is doing this is the
credit you get we tried to spread credit
as widely as we could because every
organization wants credit particularly
in the US government if there's an
effort every organization wants to
believe they did part of it and they did
so what you do is you try to make sure
that that that that goes and then you
treat people you don't Astra sighs the
people they send there's a cultural
thing to it you go in the mess hall you
go in you don't treat you don't have a
tearing of classes just because the
guy's a 22 year old Intel guy he's got
piercings all over his face and all like
that he's not less important than me or
less important than a aviator or
something like that he just brings
different expertise and it takes a
little bit to get over that because when
you first start everybody's a little bit
suspicious and everybody wants to kind
of go into your culture culture is your
problem and culture can be can become a
strength if it comes a task force
culture and that was what I mean I spent
most of my time doing that
I spent very little of my time deciding
what targets to hit her things I spent
my time making the coach for the team
work because then the team would do all
the work and that's you know that's sort
of the biggest takeaway I I came with it
thanks please join me in thanking
general McChrystal